this is Startalk can I add before you
begin yes that I you know we as I'd
majored in physics in college and in
graduate school and my PhD is in
astrophysics but there's a course I
never took but I regret it was a little
too hard for me at the time it's
probably still too hard for me and I
rely no I love poetry and I rely on
others who are familiar in these areas
to tell me what is and what isn't
I've never take agretti taking a
graduate course in field theory and
graduate field theory is the full
analysis of the forces of nature at
their deepest and most mathematical
levels and so I read about them but I've
never calculated with them okay and so
if any of these questions go there I'll
just say I didn't I didn't take that
class well that is something you and I
have in common because with my degree in
journalism and creative writing I too
did not take field theory
you